on behalf of the Weatherhead institute
and of the blinkin european institute to
welcome you here to welcome lee to speak
to thank him for this initiative and in
effect to report back on what we've been
able to accomplish with our students
inaugurating the first global scholars
programs we have here the agenda the
program so I shan't go through it except
to say that president Bollinger will
open with remarks then I as the director
of the program will speak briefly and
introduce my students then Madeleine's
Ellen who is the head of the Weatherhead
Institute will introduce her students
and her colleague professor Barnett and
then a nick Dirk's our vice president of
arts and sciences and can Pruitt the
former vice president of the global
initiatives who helped launch this and
has just been very very wonderful and
his inspiration will add comments and
then we open it up for discussion and
comment so Lee thank you
so thank you vicki it's a really
important moment for the university
because this is the return of the
pioneers who have gone out and as global
scholars have really set a pattern for
what we hope will be a much broader
educational experience for students in
the university so I am and I think we
all are really looking forward to
hearing from the students let me
introduce my wife Jean here who has been
very deeply engaged with me and
everybody else in trying to conceive of
and implement the global centers I just
have a few things to say by way of
introduction I think from my point of
view and I think there are many
different points of view about
globalization and universities my point
of view is the following I think we're
in an historic era that has two very
powerful forces at work changing the
world one is the opening of markets
throughout the world and the rise of
capitalism and the rise of foreign
investment and the rise of trade at a
level that we have not really seen
before and I don't say this as an
unchallengeable good I think there are
many many good things about this
phenomenon but I also think that there
are many things many issues that are
raised by the forces of economics and
investment and I think it is the
responsibility of universities to be
following whatever the forces are in
this case economic and to critique them
to evaluate them to review them and to
recommend what needs to be done i think
there's you only have to look at the
great recession and the need throughout
the world for a greater sense of
coherence in the way in which we
approach what is happening in order to
avoid what's happened so the first force
is economic the second major development
that is transforming the world is the
invention of a new communications
technology the internet and this often
happens I mean as as a student in my
case of technologies of communication
and their relationship to things like
freedom of speech and press I'm very
much attuned to and aware of how
transformative a new communications
technology can be and this one is quite
incredible I mean it is something where
people can communicate as we know
instantaneously and in many different
forms and it is opening up a world of
global discussion a provision of
information globally that is I think
revolutionary we're only at the
beginning of it and we all find it even
almost impossible to conceive of the
fact that 10 years ago this didn't
really exist you know maybe 50 million
people were hooked up to the internet 10
12 years ago and now there are two
billion people connected to the Internet
and that's growing by a couple of
hundred thousand people every month I
mean those statistics are staggering but
extremely telling so you have these two
forces and you have other forces just
the interactions of people across the
globe that are happening because travel
is easier in
many respects but these are really
changing our world so that's the that's
the first sort of premise and the second
premise is that this looks like it's
here to stay now we know that there have
been points in history where there have
been greater interconnections over a
series of decades and then it has
exploded and set back the processes of
globalization that may happen here but
it's fair to say I think that this has a
chance of continuing to build and the
lives of our students will be very
different from the lives that we have
led and from the lives that our parents
and our families led I have a an aunt
who has never been on an airplane in her
life I have another aunt who has never
traveled outside of California I mean
maybe that's a good thing I mean maybe
maybe all of us should wish for that I
but the I mean these are these are
amazing generational shifts so it I
think it's probably here to say and that
means that the world will look very
differently in just a few decades and we
need I think to build the foundations of
a global society just like in this
country in other countries over the
course of the last century two centuries
we had to build up a national society
with national policies national
principles national structures that
could cope with the greater
interconnectedness that was the result
of economic activity and new
technologies of communication internally
to the United States as well as other
things
so it's profound those are the forces
it's here to stay in all probability and
then comes universities and my view
universities do many many things and in
many ways some ways we don't even need
the outside world there's some parts of
what we do that are internal to our own
thinking about matters that may or may
not have any connection to the outside
world but there's a lot of what we do
that is connected to the outside world
and the inside and the outside are sort
of you know in a way a false distinction
but we do need to have some sense of
remove from the outside world we can't
be involved in every single new issue on
the other hand we can't be so detached
that we can't think about things in ways
that are fruitful so as somebody who has
been in law schools law professor who
constitutional law I know that difficult
line but nevertheless an important line
between staying aware of what's
happening and yet having the detachment
to be able to do what scholars do and
what an educational system does so we
have to think about the outside world
and the next point is that when the
world is changing in the ways that I'm
saying it is and so profoundly we then
are often as I think we are now in a
position where we are behind we know too
little or too ignorant of these changes
which are partly because it's happening
so rapidly economies move economic
forces move with such speed and the
technical
technological revolution moves with such
speed it's understandable that our
fields and our thinking are not in the
same not in the right relationship to
what's happening to the outside world
and so we need in order to play the role
that universities do and should in as I
say critiquing and reviewing and
challenging and and resisting and
helping to promote all those things that
we do in order to do that we have to be
more aware we have to educate ourselves
now we have a lot to contribute to the
world too but that's I think going to
happen what's not going to happen easily
is teaching ourselves as overcoming our
ignorance universities are doing a
variety of things not all universities
believe what I just said not all people
in universities obviously believe that
some think that they're out there to get
the brightest students in the world
we're want to do that to other
universities think they're out there to
contribute to they bring their expertise
to the world of course as I said we want
to do that to a summer setting up branch
campuses around the world some are
forming greater networks with other
institutions some are doing very little
the course we've taken is as any great
university there are many fronts we are
already probably one of the most
international global universities in on
the planet very very distinguished
scholars and teachers about the world
and that's great but the world is now
interconnected and you can understand
one part without understanding another
part and so we both need to increase our
awareness of what's happening in parts
of the world and understand the inner
connectedness so in order to do that we
need to be out there we need to be
explored
again we need to understand that people
can teach us things that we don't know
and need to know in order to perform our
responsibilities better and all of that
has led to a number of developments
which I will not reverse but one of them
is the creation of the global centers
and we now have for the first time eight
up and running can Pruitt has been the
vice president in charge of helping to
make that happen in now South Lawn mas
free it's taken over to do that we have
our directors of our global centers here
the eight they are an incredible group
of people highly distinguish the great
staff very fine facilities and we're
ready to help and facilitate people
within Columbia students and faculty to
go out and to work with local
institutions and world institutions on
the problems that exist both to make
contributions and to increase our
understanding of what is there the
global scholars are our pioneers as I
said we have many students who study
abroad but this our first group of
students who with faculty have gone out
to the set using the centers to try to
understand global issues cities middle
class and others and we'll hear about
those today when I met with the entering
students talked to the intern students
just the three weeks ago now I said to
them this is now your university with
places around the world ready to help
you be a better educated person and my
view is you really cannot count yourself
an educated person coming out
an undergraduate or graduate program
unless you have actually been to these
other countries and bend to China bend
India been to Africa and there is a kind
of magic that happens when you just
visit a place and work at a place it can
be for a very short period of time a few
days but then you read about you think
about it this there's something that
happens and invited the students to be
part of this particular conference today
but also to begin to think about how
they can structure their education in
their years here to take advantage of
this what we learned today will be the
basis for what we can do for all
students so I want to thank the Lincoln
weatherhead and the air weatherhead
Institute's the faculty and especially
the students for helping us get to this
point thank you